bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans saveaug regarde ce
soir Philippe Besson qui vient nous
parler de son dernier roman bonsoirons
merci beaucoup d'être notre grand témoin
un soir d'été chez Juliard c'est une
autofiction sur l'adolescence sur la fin
de l'innocence ça raisonne avec
l'actualité notamment celle du
harcèlement mais pas seulement c'est un
peu votre histoire histoire souvenir
tragique de vos 18 ans un fait d'hiver
une disparition dans l'île de Ray des
années 80 on en parle tous les deux tout
à l'heure dans la deuxè partie notre
grand débat ce soir faut-il inscrire
l'IVG dans la Constitution oui pour les
députés qui ont adopté le projet de loi
cette semaine c'est plus compliqué au
Sénat le président Gérard Larcher de la
Haute Assemblée s'y oppose alors cette
promesse présidentielle est-elle mal
embarqué nous en débattons dans un
instant avec nos invités enfin nos
affranchis ce soir l'humeur de l'avocat
Bertrand Perrier le billet société de
lordossi de Charlie hebbdo et puis
action planète comme chaque vendredi la
chronique écol d à Falco voilà pour le
menu on y va je vous suis ça vous
regarde top
[Musique]
générique c'est donc un débat très
important pour les femmes qui pourrai
tourner au fiasco comment protéger
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans un moment où beaucoup de pays y
compris en Europe remettent en cause
l'IVG l'inscription dans la Constitution
est-elle le meilleur rempart oui pour
les députés c'est beaucoup plus ambigu
je vous le disais au Sénat le débat il
est à la fois juridique sémantique et
très politique bonsoir Marie-Pierre xxin
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance de lesson vous avez présidé
la délégation au droits des femmes ici
même à l'Assemblée vous défendez ce
projet de loi tout comme vous Mélanie
Vogel bonsoir merci d'être là sénatrice
écologique représentant les Français fr
établi à l'étranger en revanche vous
avez des réserves ce soir Émilie
Bonivard bonsoir merci d'être à distance
depuis votre circonscription de Chambéry
député les républicains de savois enfin
bonsoir Sarah du rocherir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes la présidente du planning
familial et je crois que vous n'avez
perdu aucune minute aucune miette de ce
débat à l'Assemblée donc ça vous tient à
cœur vous nous dirai pourquoi enfin
bonsoir Paul Cassia bienvenue professeur
de droit public à l'université parien
Panthéon Sorbonne Philippe Besson
n'hésitez pas je n'hésit pas si le sujet
vous intéresse à interpeller à
interroger nos invités on commence comme
chaque soir par planter le décor
qu'est-ce qu'il prévoit ce projet de loi
pourquoi les sénateurs s'y opposent
c'est dans le recap de Bruno donet qu'on
accueille tout de suite et bonsoir mon
cher Bruno bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à tous
Alors vous avez regardé attentivement
cette question euh et vous avez
finalement un un grand un mot un mot un
grand mot j'ose dire à retenir oui et ce
mot myiam c'est le mot susceptible alors
susceptible d'abord parce que au moment
où nous parlons l'inscription de l'IVG
dans la Constitution n'est encore que
susceptible d'aboutir et ensuite parce
que si ça coince et bien c'est
essentiellement pour des histoires de
susceptibilité mais pour bien comprendre
il faut commencer par
rembobiner le film des événements tout
commence le 8 mars 2023 en pleine
journée internationale des droits des
femmes Emmanuel Macron rent age à
Giselle Alimi et et il fait une annonce
Gisel Alimi par ses mots avait fait
changer la
loi je veux aujourd'hui que la force de
ce message nous aide à changer notre
Constitution afin d'y graver la liberté
des femmes à recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse voilà il veut
graver dans le marbre de la Constitution
ce qui jusqu'ici n'est encore qu'une loi
votter en 1975 sous l'impulsion d'une
certaine Simon veille seulement voilà il
va se Horter instantanément à la
susceptibilité des constitutionnalistes
qui lui font observer que et ben ça ne
changerait absolument rien la question
si vous voulez de de de l'avortement et
et et de ce ce projet de loi
constitutionnel c'est que il ne sert
strictement à rien c'est un copier collé
du droit positif existant allons bon pas
d'accord avec les spécialistes de la
Constitution les association féministe
les élus de la majorité et les députés
de gauche qui rappellent que comme c'est
récemment arrivé en Pologne en Hongrie
ou aux États-Unis aux États-Unis la loi
aussi est susceptible susceptible de
changer mais la plus grande
susceptibilité Bruno vous l'avez observé
dans les rangs politiques oui le
chatouilleux en chef s'appelle gérrard
Larcher si l'IVG était menacé croyez-moi
je je me battrai pour qu'il soit
maintenu mais je pense que la
Constitution n'est pas un catalogue de
droits sociaux et sociétaux le président
du Sénat est favorable à l'IVG mais il
n'est pas d'accord pour qu'on l'inscrive
dans la Constitution alors pourquoi et
bien vraemblablement pour une affaire de
susceptibilité il est ici question de
mots mais surtout de parcours législatif
je vous explique en 2022 une première
proposition de loi a été examiné et
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale la
proposition est alors partie au Sénat
qui par amendement a remplacé le mot de
droit à l'IVG substitué par celui de
liberté mais cette semaine le
gouvernement a écrit non plus liberté
mais liberté garantie et ça ça n'a pas
plu du tout au sénateur à l'image de
Bruno retaillot qui l'a dit très
fermement hier matin liberté garantie ah
oui mais vous savez le diable est dans
le détail quand vous dites liberté
garantie ça c'est enroit ça veut dire un
droit justement donc ça n'est pas pareil
que une liberté voilà mais ce qui a
surtout froisser les sénateurs c'est le
timing l'agenda car vous savez he Myriam
pour réviser la Constitution il faut
l'accord du Congrès c'est-à-dire des
3/5è des députés et des sénateurs or si
les députés ont déjà voter oui c'était
avanttiier les sénateurs eux n'ont pas
encore débattu de la question ils n'ont
prévu de le faire qu'à la toute fin du
mois de février le Hi c'est que le
Président de la République malheureux a
déjà fixé la date du congrès au 4 mars
prochain et ça ça a très méchamment
chionné les amis de Bruno
rotaillo le gouvernement était maladroit
pourquoi parce que il a il a indiqué
qu'il voulait réunir le Congrès le 5
mars or nous on va discuter quelques
jours avant si c'est cela ça veut dire
au Sénat garde à vous et vous voterez
conforme
par rapport à ce qu'a voté l'Assemblée
nationale où l'on comprend Myriam qu'en
politique aussi il faut savoir ménager
les susceptibilités et se souvenir de
cette jolie mise en garde signée
montesquieux qui a écrit il ne faut
toucher à la constitution qu'en
tremblant tu m'étonnes merci beaucoup
Bruno c'était très clair le défi est
relevé c'est le 5 mars le Congrès mais
sinon 10 sur 10 bravo bravo à vous alors
mariepierrix c'est compliqué parce qu'il
y a de la manœvre politique il y a aussi
les 3 cè à réunir pour changer la
constitution et puis il y a les femmes
et puis il y a le contexte politique
dans le monde et et en Europe est-ce que
déjà sur la menace on entend beaucoup la
droit dire mais arrêtez l'IVG n'est pas
menacé dans notre pays est-ce que est-ce
que vous êtes sur cette ligne là est-ce
qu'un jour 2027 plus tard ce droit
pourrait être remis en cause très
honnêtement est-ce que il y a 10 ou 15
ans on aurait questionné les Américains
sur la remise en question du droit à
l'avortement sur leur leur terre leur
territoire euh ils se sont ils auraient
senti ce droit menacé je ne le crois pas
il y avait d'ailleurs à l'époque euh de
grandes défenseuse à l'intérieur de la
Cour suprême qui garantissait ce droit
et puis euh les aléas euh politiques euh
étant ceux qu'ils sont et bien
effectivement euh le droit à
l'avortement a été remis en question euh
aux États-Unis la la j'ai envie de dire
la la la terre d'une démocratie euh
historique sur laquelle euh
effectivement euh on on Nimagine pas
ce sûr que c'est c'est réversible et on
ne on ne ne ne présageons pas de ce qui
peut se passer sur nos sur notre
territoire on voit d'ailleurs que en
Europe les antichoix j'imagine on en
reparlera tout à l'heure avance grignote
savent savent très bien d'ailleurs
comment procéder et donc d'ailleurs le
rassemblement national c'était pardon de
le dire intéressant les propos qu'ils
ont tenu dans l'émissque disaiit très
bien mais nous ne remettrons pas le
droit à l'IVG en question mais comment
ils le font ils le font en grignotant le
droit c'est ce que Orban a fait
notamment en Hongrie c'est ce qui s'est
passé en Pologne euh en mettant des
embus sur le parcours des femmes donc
c'est ça qui est en question
effectivement il faut absolument insire
ce droit dans notre pacte social et donc
donc cette dans la norme suprême de
manière à pouvoir le garantir comme le
propose le gouvernement alors Mélanie
Vogel pour une fois la gauche est
d'accord avec Renaissance puisqu'on se
souvient d'ailleurs qu'au départ c'était
une proposition de loi issue du camp
insoumis Mathilde Panau il est menacé il
pourrait l'être et ça suffit pour se
réunir tous euh les représentants de la
nation pour l'inscrire dans la norme
suprême alors d'abord je voudrais juste
revenir parce que j'aime bien euh
l'honnêteté intellectuelle sur la
manière dont ça a été présenté euh pour
euh mentionner le fait que ça a pas
commencé le 8 mars 2023 avec
l'engagement d'Emmanuel Macron euh c'est
une demande des des associations
féministes et des féministes depuis des
décennies et là aventure parlementaire a
commencé au Sénat avec une proposition
loi que j'avais déposé qui avait été
signée par de nombreux groupes et y
compris des sénateurs et des sénatrices
effectivement de renaissance parce que
c'est sur ce point-là quelque chose sur
lequel nous pouvons nous réunir qui
ensuite avait été repris effectivement
au à l'Assemblée nationale par le groupe
insoumis puis qui est revenu au sénatut
mettre à l'abri la lo veille c'est
simplement pour alors faut la mettre à
l'abri dans la je réponds maintenant sur
pourquoi on fait ça est-ce que c'est
utile et pourquoi c'est tellement
important c'est éalement important parce
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement le droit à
l'IVG n'est garanti que par la loi et
une loi une autre loi peut la défaire
inscrire cette protection dans la
Constitution c'est lui donner une
meilleure protection puisque ça
permettrait que si jamais une majorité
qui serait suffisante pour changer la
loi mais pas suffisante pour changer la
constitution voulez attaquer la loi et
bien elle ne pourrait pas le faire c'est
la raison pour laquelle on veut inscrire
le droit Lig dans la Constitution on
peut avoir ensuite des débats techniques
et j'espère qu'on les aura sur quelle
est la meilleure formulation à quel
point elle est efficace et cetera mais
oui c'est utile ce n'est pas que quelque
chose de symbolique même si j'aime pas
trop quand on dit que symbolique c'est
pas très intéressant il y a aussi des
effets des symboles qui ont des effets
réels dans la vie euh mais c'est quelque
chose de très concret si un jour on
attaque le droit à l'IVG le Conseil
constitutionnel aujourd'hui n'a rien
pour dire vous pouvez pas le faire alors
je vais aller voir le
constitutionnaliste dans un instant mais
juste pour comprendre vous vous siégez
au Sénat ouai euh vous avez voté le
compromis qu'a proposé alors il s'agit
de Philippe bah il faut lui Hage
sénateur les républicains compromis qui
proposait ce mot de liberté de recourir
à l'IVG à la place du mot de droit à
l'IVG ça vous l'avez voter pour que au
fond il y ait le maximum de de députés
et qu'on arrive à au 35e Infiné c'est
bien ça voilà pour être très clair moi
la la proposition que j'avais faite au
Sénat déjà en octobre elle était déjà
issue d'un compromis entre différents
groupes puisque la proposition très
ambitieuse des écologies je savais très
bien qu'elle n'avait aucune chance
malheureusement aujourd'hui d'être voté
au Sénat ensuite assemblée ils ont aussi
fait un compromis ils ont voté quelque
chose qui était aussi euh voilà discuté
entre différents groupes ensuite c'est
revenu au Sénat nous avons encore fait
un compromis pourquoi nous l'avons voté
d'abord parce que il me semblait
important de montrer qu'il y avait une
majorité parlementaire dans les deux
chambres des discussions toujours à
avoir sur la formulation mais qu'il
existe aujourd'hui en France une
majorité au Parlement pour faire cela et
ensuite parce que à la fin de l'histoire
le meilleur texte qu'on puisse avoir
c'est le texte le plus ambitieux
possible qui peut être adopté un texte
plus ambitieux qui peut pas être adopté
bah il est pas meilleur en fait parce
que ce qu'il faut c'est que ça marche
alors la question maintenant c'est
est-ce que c'est plus protégé est-ce que
déjà entre le mot liberté le mot garanti
mais déjà Paul casscia le droit à
l'avortement inscrit dans la
Constitution ça prévient de quoi si la
loi veille est abrogée ça n'est pas
possible de le faire puisque elle sera
constitutionnalisé en tout cas le droit
sera constitutionnalisé et pas la loi
veille en elle-même elle sera pas
constitutionnalisée mais mais le
principe de la possibilité pour les
femmes de recourir à l'IVG sera
constitutionnalisé de sorte qu'il sera
pas possible d'abroger la loi va il sera
pas possible d'interdire l'avortement
s'il y a une constitutionnalisation
telle qu'elle se préfigure donc c'est
une forme de protection ça on est bien
d'accord bien évidment bien évidemment
alors liberté garantie oui c'est-à-dire
la dernière version j'essaie d'expliquer
parce que pour ceux qui nous suivent
c'est pas évident hein on prend le
programme en cours c'est technique
liberté garantie c'est la dernière
version oui c'est celle du gouvernement
projet de loi qui a été adopté mercredi
euh c'est ça revient à dire droit alors
liberté et droit contrairement à une
opinion très répendue c'est exactement
la même chose le Conseil d'État l'a dit
l'a rappelé dans son avis sur le projet
de loi constitutionnel il n'y a pas de
différence en matière constitutionnelle
entre des droits et des libertés pas de
différence de valeurs pas de différence
de hiérarchie c'est pare ce son pour
choisisse le mot droit ou le mot liberté
c'est la même protection juridique
absolument donc pourquoi c'estes débats
sémantiques et peut-être parce que tout
le monde n'est pas constitutionnaliste
d'accord bon ben c'est très clair et
quand Gérard Larché dit la Constitution
n'est pas un catalogue de droits sociaux
et sociétau est-ce qu'il a raison ou
est-ce qu'il a tort je dois vous dire
que ça m'a fait un sacré choc que le
président du Sénat dise ceci parce que
je sais pas ce qu'il lui a pris il
suffit d'ouvrir la Constitution la le
préambule de la déclaration de 1946 qui
est un texte constitutionnel qui est
appliqué tous les jours par toutes les
juridictions de France est un catalogue
de droits sociaux et sociétaux exemple
exemple le droit le droit de grève
exemple le droit à l'enseignement le
droit à la santé le droit à accéder à un
enseignement public et gratuit à tous
les degrés il y a tout un catalogue de
droits sociaux et sociétaux il sont dans
le bloc de constitutionnalité au début
1958 je pense que Gérard larch en est
avisé Émilie Bonivard pour les
républicains il connaît pas la
Constitution française Gérard
Larcher non moi je voudrais répondre
à je m'entends un peu en écho
les inconvénients du Skype mais juste
pour me répondre et vous pourrez donner
votre position juste après Gérard
Larcher qu'est-ce qu'il lui a appris de
dire
ça ben vous pouvez demander à ce sera
peut-être plus simple non vous êtes en
désaccord avec lui je je je le non non
moi je suis pas en désaccord avec Gérard
Larché on respecte quelque chose de
fondamental dans ma famille politique
qui est la liberté euh de de de
conscience et la liberté absolue sur les
questions notamment qui engagent des
questions éthiques ce qui a indiqué
Gérard Larcher je crois de manière un
petit peu plus importante c'est et pour
moi c'est le point fondamental c'est si
on inscrit dans la
Constitution la liberté de recourir à
l'IVG et si le gouvernement est honnête
quand il dit qu'il souhaite consacrer la
loi veille dans l'IBG il faut dans ce
cas consacrer toute la loi
veille je m'explique vous avez dans la
loi veille l'article 1 qui est le
principe le respect du du principe du
respect de l'être humain dès le
commencement de sa vie euh et qui est
lié avec le droit des femmes à recourir
à l'IVG la liberté des femmes pardon à
recourir à l'IVG donc nous ce qui nous
préoccupe c'est
euh la garantie que cet équilibre de la
loi veille et que toute la loi veille
soit inscrit euh dans ce projet de loi
constitutionnel ou en tout cas qu'il ne
puisse y avoir aucun doute sur le fait
qu'un autre principe à valeur
constitutionnelle c'est-à-dire le
respect de la dignité de de la vie
humaine contre toute forme
d'asservissement et de dégradation de
même que le principe de la protection de
l'être humain dès le commencement de sa
vie soit respecté or nous avons une
inquiétude étude qui est de se dire si
l'on inscrit uniquement le recours à
l'IVG avec une liberté garantie euh
monsieur l'a dit la liberté c'est
équivalent au droit euh et que l'on
n'inscrit pas clairement un autre
principe à valeur
constitutionnelle qui lui ne du coup
sera déséquilibré par rapport à à l'IVG
qui aujourd'hui est aussi un principe à
valeur constitutionnelle déduit de la
liberté de la femme dans ce cas on
risque d'inscrire un déséquilibre dans
la Constitution et d'ouvrir une porte
possible à un autre excès euh qui est le
fait que il y a des positions qui
indiquent que la femme doit pouvoir
avoir accès à
l'IVG comprend c'est pas facile à
distance madame Bard ce que vous dites
en en clair si je vous ai bien compris
c'est que cette liberté garantie
pourrait ouvrir un droit opposable à
l'IVG Mme Mor délai c'est bien ça
oui bien bah disons que comme on a plus
les mêmes le même le même niveau de
protection oui dans les fites oui c'est
clair voilà alors je vais me tourner
vers le planning familial Sarah du
Rocher vous avez tout suivi vous voyez
un petit peu les les les
tensions c'est un peu c'est un peu
juridique mais cette question si si on
allait jusqu'à la
constitutionnalisation vous pensez que
ça pourrait ouvrir comme ça la
possibilité à des femmes de
vouloir exiger ce droit même si les
délais légaux sont sont dépassés alors
je pense qu'il y a une réponse de la
part du ministre de la justice moi je
suis du planning familial et donc du
coup je bah moi je rebondis juste sur le
fait que ces craintes peuvent être
émises mais là on est en train de parler
de constitutionnaliser le droit à
l'avortement c'est bien le législateur
qui décide les délais et donc évidemment
que le planning familial à des positions
ça a été dit au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale mais au-delà de ça nous on
parle de en tant que militante féministe
en tant que association du planning et
sur les questions des délais je rassure
tout de suite les députés àair il a
fallu 20 ans pour augmenter de 2
semaines 14 semaines non mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que c'est des
batailles continues et et de se dire que
à chaque fois qu'il y a des batailles
sur l'avortement pour améliorer la loi
veille tout simplement parce que c'est
les réalités de terrain que le planning
familial voit et on voit les difficultés
quand vous posiez la question est-ce
qu'il y a des menaces moi je vous le dis
il y a des menaces sur le droit à
l'avortement et ben tout simplement
aujourd'hui il y a énormément de
désinformation c'està-dire que on a des
ennemis de
l'avortement la première chose que font
les femmes juste pour enfin elles sont
enceintes elles souhaitent avorter elles
vont aller taper sur internet il y a une
chance sur deux de tomber mais sur un
site antichoix qui va faire la
désinformation ça pose la question de
l'éducation à la sexualité à la à
l'information en fait que les personnes
ont et puis la deuxième chose c'est
quand il faut trouver un médecin et là
on se retrouve sur des territoires où
parfois il n'y a pas de médecin il n
pasè n'est pas garanti légal accès à
l'IVG c'est pas garanti et et moi je
voudrais rappeler enfin moi je je
regardais le le reportage juste avant
enfin là on est en train on a un moment
historique enfin nous on a une confiance
forte au
parlementa on l'attend on l'attend parce
que c'est un travail depuis des années
avec des parlementaires avec Mélanie
Vogel avec mathil Panau avec Laurence
Rossignol avec les associations de la
société civile évidemment avec
mariepierrexin aussi où ça a été des
batailles sur l'avortement depuis
longtemps à chaque fois pour les
féministes et pour les les
parlementaires alliés c'est des
batailles et je pense en effet sur
l'avortement enfin de faire rentrer
l'IVG dans la Constitution ça va pas
tout résoudre mais par contre c'est une
pierre pour nous qui est importante il
faut des victoires pour les féministes
il faut des défaites pour les antichoix
et je pense que là on est à quelques
semaines de vraiment avoir une belle
victoire et ça serait grâce au
parlementaire grâce aux sénateurs et
sénatrices et députés et grâce aux
associations derrière avec qui le
travail a été construit ben on entend la
passion de la militante la présidente du
planning familial il est où le grand
débat dans dans la société sur le sur le
sujet c'est vrai que on s'enferme aussi
beaucoup dans les bataille juridique
alors que vous nous dites attention
c'est historique moi je pense que je
partage entièrement votre passion et je
comprends qu'il y ait des débats
techniques et politiques mais alors
justement il faut pas s'enfermer dans
ces débats je pense que ce débat il est
largement plus important que ça ça et et
et il faut revenir à l'essentiel et à
une forme de bon sens est-ce que ce
droit peut-être menacé oui évidemment il
est en Europe aux États-Unis au
quotidien en France donc il faut le
protéger quand le le président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher trouve une s d'arguments
complètement fallacieux pour expliquer
pourquoi il s'ppose parce qu'on a bien
compris c'est un argument qui n'a aucun
sens c'est une façon d'ergotter qui
démontre qu'au fond au fond il en veut
pas la réalité c'est qu'il en veut pas
et qu'on revient à cette société où les
hommes considèrent certain d'un certain
âge très conservateurs considère que
quand même ces histoires de bonnes
femmes ça va bien parce que c'est ça que
ça raconte derrière pardon mais c'est ça
que ça raconte derrière et donc
évidemment qu'il faut protéger ce droit
fondamental parce que c'est un droit
fondamental là aussi posons-nous une
question simple est-ce que c'est un
droit fondamental ou un droit secondaire
accessoire qui aurait comme ça une
importance très limitée non évidemment
que c'est un droit fondamental donc on
le met dans le texte
fondamental revenons à des choses de bon
sens voilà revenons à des choses de bon
sens madame Bonivard c'est vrai que la
droite a pu être un peu à la traain sur
un certain nombre d'avancé de de droits
sociétaux je pense au mariage pour tous
et même la PMA pour toutes et puis à
chaque fois la droite a expliqué qu'elle
n'allait pas remettre finalement ses ses
droits acquis et voté par par la la
représentation nationale qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à Philippe Besson
non je réponds quand même que le la loi
veille c'est sous zacira qui vait r des
de même que la contraception donc non
non mais enfin je veux dire
si est-ce que je peux parler allez-y oui
jeen prie merci euh c'està-dire que si
cette loi n'avait pas été déposée par le
gouvernement de Jack n on est député on
sait comment ça marche c'estàd faut que
le gouvernement accepte de de déposer ce
ce projet de loi pour qu'il soit voté et
bien il n'aurait pas eu de possibilité
d'être voté et sur ces sujets ils sont
toujours transpartisans moi je suis pas
de mauvaise foi je dis pas qu'à la
droite on a tous le même avis mais je
souhaite aussi qu'on soit honnête et
qu'on reconnaisse que la
contraception le remboursement de la
contraception et également la loi veille
l'avortement c'est sous des
gouvernements de droite je dis pas que
toute la droite l'a voté mais je ne veux
pas non plus qu'on dise le contraire
mais
aujourd'hui simplement je souhaiterais
réagir il y a vous avez indiquer un
droit fondamental alors le
constitutionnaliste nous dira si c'est
un droit fondamental ou pas ça l' pas en
réalité mais tout droits fondamentaux
tout droit fondamental à la rigueur est
limité par un d'autres droits
fondamentaux et moi c'est ce que je dis
moi j'étais prête à à voter ce cette
inscription parce que je je je crois
qu'il y a une possibilité de menace mais
en revanche là où je ne suis pas du tout
rassuré c'est que un autre extrême un
autre écueil que je refuse comme
constituant comme être humain aussi
avant d'être une femme c'est le fait que
on puisse
outrepasser un autre principe
fondamental qui est le le respect de la
vie humaine dès son commencement sachant
que la loi veille avait indiqué que
avant les 10 semaines c'était la liberté
de la femme qui prévalait après les 10
c'était le le respect de la vie humaine
et que on a effectivement législateur
décalé ce à 14 semain mais je ne veux
pas que ce droit devienne opposable
c'est bien dit c'est très clair vous
l'avez bien expliqué j'ai simplement une
question à notre à la personne qui est
sur le plateau qui est spécialisé en en
droit constitutionnel je vous prie pouro
pourquoi Monsieur CIA on ne peut pas
inscrire toute la loi veille c'estàdire
le respect de la vie humaine dès son
commencement de la même dans dans la
Constitution en toutes lettrre parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est que sur des
déductions oui précisément la
Constitution c'est pas une loi et que
dans la on a les grands principes de
droits fondamentaux les grands principes
d'organisation de l'État et ces grands
principes sont ensuite déclinés comme
vous comme ici tout le monde le sait
soit dans les lois organiques soit dans
des lois ordinaires soit dans des
règlements pour donc
répondreame qui pose une question
parfaitement légitime de l'équilibre de
du droit des droits et bien cette
question elle a déjà été évoqué par le
le garde des saau à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a de TR jours
la de la personne humaine c'est déjà un
principe constitutionnel c'est un
principe qui figure dans le préambule de
la Constitution de 1946 c'est un
principe qui qui est appliqué par les
juridictions et ce principe viendra
contrebalancer le cas échéant la liberté
de recourir à l'IVG et cette balance
entre deux droits c'est ce que fait
quotidiennement le Conseil
constitutionnel et juridiction ordinaire
donc il y a pas de printe à avir sur ce
point peut-être qu'il faudrait laisser
un peu de temps au sénateur tout
simplement la date du 4 mars alors c'est
le 4 mars finalement ce congrès c'est
c'est aussi une manière de leur dire
voilà vous êtes une chambre
d'enregistrement alors imaginez
l'inverse que le le le gouvernement
propose un projet de loi sans que le
Président de la République derrière
préempte une date pour réunir le Congrès
vous imaginez bien qu'on réunit pas le
Congrès comme ça en 5 minutes on aurait
dit oui évidemment c'est un coup de com
il proposent un projet de loi mais
derrière ils envisagent pas de
Ré ser très honnêtement ce serait pas
raisonnable la réalité c'est que nous
avons aujourd'hui un texte de compromis
ça a été dit qui a été adopté dans des
termes nous le disons quasi identiques à
la fois par l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat sur la base d'une proposition de
loi nous savons que pour qu'une
proposition de loi ne peut pas faire
l'objet de d'une réunion du Congrès donc
il fallait un projet de loi de la part
du gouvernement ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement le président le président
de la République propose une date pour
réunir le Congrès qu'en fait tout j'ai
envie de dire que tout se passait bien
tout se déroule bien jusqu'à ce que
pardonudrais dire quand même un mot sur
ce point jusqu'à ce que coup théâtre de
la semaine puisque c'est bien l'objet de
également de cette émission ce soir coup
théâtre de la semaine ou Gérard Larché
et Monsieur rotaillot explique à quel
point finalement ils n'en veulent pas
tout simplement disons-le on va pas dire
on va le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
les droits fondamentaux des femmes alors
même que nous sommes regardés par le
monde entier pourrait faire les frais
d'une discorde interne chez leslr et
notamment au Sénat entre monsieur RET et
Monsieur larch soyons raisonable c'est
la sénatrice vous vous les côtoyez vous
les connaissez leslr à l'Assemblée vous
vous en pensez quoi vous êtes dans
l'opposition vous dites c'est pas
forcément le 4 mars a pris cette cause
est si importante qui
peut-êre revenir sur ce qu'a dit Gérard
Larché la première chose c'est que le
fait de dire la Constitution n'est pas
un catalogue de droit ça a été dit il
faut le répéter faut que les gens
comprennent bien il y a un catalogue de
droit dans la Constitution française le
sujet c'est que ce catalogue de droit
s'est arrêté à ce qui était considéré
comme étant des droits fondamentaux en
1946 en 1946 le droit à l'IVG n'était
pas considéré par la société française
comme un droit fondamental méritant sa
place au sommet de la hiérarchie des
normes aujourd'hui en 2024 ça a changé
c'est pour ça qu'il faut le mettre
aujourd'hui la deuxième chose c'est que
Gérard Larcher a aussi dit l'IVG n'est
pas menacé Sarah du rocher l'a très bien
expliquer il y a des menaces concrètes
au droit livivg aujourd'hui mais surtout
s'il n'est pas menacé par les
parlementaires aujourd'hui vous
comprenez bien que c'est aujourd'hui
qu'il faut le mettre dans la
Constitution quand il sera menacé mais
ce sera trop tard il faut les 3/5e pour
le mettre dans la Constitution c'est le
but de cette affaire c'est de le rendre
plus protégé que par une loi donc c'est
maintenant qu'il faut faire et la
troisième chose c'est que qui a voté
depuis la loi veille contre toutes les
avancées du droit à l'IVG la droite y
compris la droite sénatoriale et donc
ces personnes-là qui ont voté il y a
l'année dernière contre l'allongement du
délai de 12 à 4 de semaines la loi
Gillot viennent nous dire aujourd'hui
mais comment pourriez-vous penser que
nous remettrions en cause le droit et
l'vg aujourd'hui alors qu'ils ont voté
contre ce qui est notre droit
aujourd'hui il y a pas 30 ans il y a 1
an donc c'est aussi contre cela que nous
protégeons je voudrais juste dire une
dernière chose rapidement s'il vous
plaît très
rapidement Gérard Larché a toujours été
opposé à l'introduction du droit LVG
dans la Constitution c'était le cas
l'année dernière quand le Sénat a voté
pour je ne comprends pas la surprise
l'émotion qui est générée par cette
déclaration qui correspond exactement à
ses positions depuis toujours la
dernière fois malgré son opposition le
Sénat a voté pour au sein du Sénat la
voie gérardarché elle ne vaut pas plus
que la mienne elle vaut d'ailleurs même
un peu moins parce qu'il ne votera pas
et donc c'est les une voie de passage
même au Sénat bien compris Sarah du
rocher l'attente du terrain elle est là
malheureusement on n pas le temps de
vous passer notre reportage qui montrait
que on a ouvert par un décret aux
sages-femmes la possibilité de pratiquer
certains IVG instrumental et pas
simplement les accouchements euh l'accès
c'est toujours un sujet en France
aujourd'hui et ce genre de de débat
c'est c'est des signals même si c'est
symbolique qui peuvent peut-être vous
aider sur le terrain mais signaux
pardonnez-moi en fait je pense que il y
a vraiment ce symbole mais aussi se dire
que aujourd'hui c'est important de
l'inscrire je ne vois pas pourquoi il y
aurait une exception à la française si
un jour l'extrême droite arrive au
pouvoir ou si des conservateurs il y a
pas besoin d'être d'extrême droite pour
avoir des propos sexiste anti-avortement
aussi arrive au pouvoir je ne vois pas
pourquoi ça serait pas remis en question
on le voit en Pologne on le voit en
Hongrie on le voit aux États-Unis on le
voit partout que à chaque fois que
l'extrême droite arrive au pouvoir on
attaque le droit des femmes on attaque
l'avortement et le droit des personnes
LGBT qu' y a a plus donc moi je voudrais
juste dire quand même juste deux petits
mots c'est que en fait nous on parle
avec les féministes du monde entier on
parle avec les polonaise on parle avec
les Hongroises et les États-Unis et on
nous demande qu'est-ce qui va se passer
ça serait vraiment un écho Gigantes
que la France constitutionnalise pas que
pour nous mais pour toutes les
féministes du monde entier on nous
regarde donc voilà il faut que les
parlementaires soyz soyez à hauteur
voilà le le message est passé l'appel
est lancé merci à vous et pardonneznous
mie Bonivard c'est toujours plus
difficile à distance de depuis la Savoie
mais quelque chose me dit qu'il y a
quand même une voix de passage au Sénat
et quelque chose me dit aussi que voilà
vous n'avez pas dit votre dernier mot
vous qui avez voté je le rappelle ce
projet de loi à l'Assemblée comme député
des républicaines merci à vous merci
d'être venu débattre sur ce plateau vous
restez avec moi Philippe Besson dans une
dizaine de minutes vous les voyez les
partis prid nos afranchis ce soir le
regard de maître Bertrand Perrier sur la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
la loi immigration une nouvelle
chroniqueuse à votre droite Lord aossi
grand reporter à Charlie viendra nous
parler de l'affaire oua Castera qui n'en
finit pas de faire polémique et puis a
Falco de quoi nous parlez-vous cette
semaine dans Action planè et ben face à
la colère des agriculteurs on se demande
s'il ne faudrait pas en fait plus de
transformation écologique pour les aider
à tout à l'heure les amis mais d'abord
Philippe Besson on va partir sur l'île
doré et t85 une bande de jeunes
insouciant ils ont l'avenir devant eux
ils vont connaître un drame la
disparition d'un des leur un soir d'été
c'est chez Julia regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marco pommier interview
juste
après si on vous invite Philippe
Besson c'est parce que le roman du
sensible a encore frappé un soir d'été
l'histoire d'un drame que vous avez vécu
l'année de vos 18 ans sur l'île de Ray
lorsque Nicolas un membre de votre bande
d'amis disparaît mystérieusement est-il
mort énigme insoluble la fin de
l'insouciance vous savez vous pourquoi
il faut que les belles histoires
finissent mal 23e roman pour le maître
de l'autofiction que vous êtes écrivain
dramaturge scénariste dans votre nouveau
vos livres on s'interroge sur le rapport
à la mort sur le bouleversement qu'elle
représente à l'âge de l'adolescence à
l'âge de l'innocence questionnement
aussi sur notre rapport aux autres il
faut parfois que quelqu'un disparaisse
pour qu'on apprenne la valeur de la vie
pour comprendre à quel point elle est
fragile et précieuse la vie
connaissons-nous vraiment les gens qui
nous entourent la perche est trop belle
Philippe Besson pour ne pas vous parler
aussi d'Emmanuel Macron un temps fasciné
un brun courtisan séduit par
l'intelligence de ce jeune président
pour qui vous avez de l'affection et de
l'amitié mais trop à droite selon vous
vous flinguez la pire réforme au pire
moment celle des retraites l'affaire de
pardieu achève d'entériner vos
désaccords lorsque le chef de l'État
dénonce une chasse à l'homme les propos
que que gérarde pardieu tient dans
complément d'enquête c'est des propos
abjects insoutenables aucun homme aucun
homme ne doit se sentir autorisé à tenir
les propos qu'il tient et si un homme
tient ces propos là c'est un port et
vous l'avez dit ça oui comme tel ce soir
Philippe bon notre question va de soi
reconnaissez-vous aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron
réponse oui je le reconnais alors nous
avons des liens d'affection ces liens
ils n'ont pas changé ils étaient ils
existaient avant qu'il ne soit président
ils existent encore aujourd'hui ils
existeront quand il ne le sera plus est-
qu'il a beaucoup changé et mon AFF je
commence comme ça mon affection n'est
pas excès sur son statut ou sa
popularité et cetera mais cette
affection elle va aussi avec des
désaccords profonds sur le plan
politique que j'ai on les a entendu très
clairement et d'ailleurs vous les
assumez et et et je pense que il écoute
quand non non c'est c'est c'est une de
ces difficultés c'estd que vous pouvez
tout lui dire à Emmanuel Macron vraiment
c'est pas quelqu'un qui se vexe et
cetera mais à la fin il décide ce qu'il
veut ce que je comprends d'ailleurs il
est président de la République et pas
moi donc il fait ce qu'il veut mais je
pense que il a oublié la promesse
originelle l'ADN de son engagement qui
était et de droite et de gauche
aujourd'hui il gouverne très clairement
à droite avec même un petit parfum de
vieille France vra vieille France était
le titre de libération pour que la
France reste la
franceuniforme le bon sens
l'utoritéorité mesdames faites des
enfants enfin la blouse à l'école il y a
quand même un côté bon
je je me reconnais dans l'autorité
républicaine et dans l'autorité du
maître ça je trouve ça très bien le
reste je suis un peu il est devenu très
libéral et très conservateur et je ne
suis ni l'un ni l'A aut mais ça reste
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai énormément
d'affection un soir d'été votre romance
c'est aussi d'une certaine façon une une
forme d'éloge à la nostalgie oui une
bande de jeunes à l'été 85 se retrouve
dans l'île de Ray à courir les plages à
courir les discothèques c'est l'île de
Ray que vous chérissez c'est l'île de
Ray il y a longtemps 40 ans sans chichi
celle des campings celle des Barac à
frit on est très très très loin de l'île
de Ray des rendez-vous mondains bobo
parisiens c'était important pour vous de
raconter ce décor là cette France là qui
n'est plus oui parce que c'est c'est ma
jeunesse c'est mon enfance mon
adolescence j'ai découvert la mer en
traversant le le voilà en prenant le bac
entre la la paliss et sablanau entre la
Rochel et l'île deay donc ça m'est resté
cet éblouissement originel et c'est vrai
que à l'époque voilà on allait au
camping on plantait sa tente ou on
montait sa caravane voilà et puis et
puis le soir il y avait on mangeait du
saucissons dans des boles en plastique
sur les tables en formic dans les
campings il y avait les ona pas portable
il y avait pas de portable donc c
que on savait pas comment se retrouver
mais c'était formable parce qu'on nétait
pas non plus comment dirais-je heurté ou
rattrapé par le fracas du monde c'estàd
que ni par l'urgence on acceptait la
lenteur on acceptait la difficulté à se
retrouver et puis l'actualité nous
arrivait comme une rumeur lointaine
comme un clapoti cette année là on se
disait tiens il paraît qu'il y a un
bateau qui s'appelle le Rainbow Warrior
qui a été coulé mais on s'en foutait un
peu on avait 18 ans donc se foutait de
beaucoup de choses laala et
l'incertitude existit encore oui c'était
merveilleux c'était c'était formidable
pour ça Philippe a 18 ans il retrouve
ses amis d'enfants le fils du pêcheur et
du boucher et puis d'autres qui vont se
greffer à la bande dont Nicolas
mélancolique distant qui dessine semaine
d'insouciance jusqu'à sa disparition
brutale alors c'est pas du tout la
première fois que vous écrivez sur la
disparition c'est un thème qui vous h h
ça me hente parce que parce que moi je
fais partie d'abordune génération qui a
connu la décimation moi j'ai eu 20 ans
donc en
87 en 89 92 95 mes amis sont morts il
m'urit beaucoup quand je voulais leur
parler il fallait que j'aille dans un
cimetière et que je me recueille sur
leur tombe c'est comme ça que je suis
devenu écrivain d'ailleurs parce que
c'était difficile de seulement parler à
des tombe donc je me suis dit tiens je
vais faire des livres et donc je je les
livres ça lutte contre la disparition ça
lutte contre l'absence ça lutte contre
la mort et au fond ce qui m'arrive dans
l'été 85 c'est la confrontation avec la
première disparition alors elle a pas la
même cause que c'est celle qui arrivera
un peu plus tard mais c'est la
confrontation avec ça avec l'idée que
quelqu'un est là et puis il ne va plus
être là donc la confrontation avec la
finitude et c'est un un âge charnière
j'ai 18 ans donc à 18 ans c'est l'âge
des possible on croit que l'avenir nous
appartient on croit que rien n grave que
rien est sérieux qu' va rien nous
arriver et puis tout d'un coup c'est la
fin de l'innocence la fin de
l'insouciance parce que vous comprenez
que la vie c'est une chose
extraordinairement fragile et que ça
peut le temps d'une chanson vous
échapper des mains et ça ouvre presque
brutalement malgré soit la boîte de
Pandor des questions qu'est-ce que j'ai
pas vu ou qui était-il vraiment euh je
me sens coupableou ça aussi ça me h
c'était dans dans c'était dans ce C
n'est pas inf FIV aussi le livre de
l'année dernière c'est sur le féminicide
et le fils qui racontait sa mère morte
sous les coup du père et qui disait
pourquoi j'ai pas vu pourquoi j'ai rien
compris pourquoi j'ai pas vu venir et
c'était pareil là c'estàdire que il y a
des gens autour de vous qui vous qui
vous disent des choses qui envoie des
signaux alors certes ils sont faibles
mais vous avez pas perçu parce que vous
êtes dans autre chose ils ont déposé des
indices des petits cailloux blancs et
vous les avez pas aperçu et quand quand
l'irréparable est arrivé c'est trop tard
justement et vous vous dites pourquoi
j'ai été si in attentif pourquoi j'ai
été si incurieux pourquoi j'ai rien
compris et quand on refait le film à
l'envers tout d'un coup évidemment on
est dévoré par la culpabilité la le
remord c'est un très bonne chose pour
écrire des livres h vous êtes le maître
de l'autofiction mais là depuis tout à
l'heure vous dites je et votre héros
s'appelle Philippe oui la part de la
réalité a tout dévoré finalement sur la
fiction j'espère que non parce que
j'adore faire fiction et j'adore
inventer des histoires et même quand je
fais autofiction mon désir il est moins
de témoigner ou de faire un récit que de
faire littérature je m'explique ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas tant de raconter
mon histoire même si c'est ça que je
fais très clairement dans ce livre- là
je vais pas me cacher derrière mon petit
doigt mais c'est moins de raconter mon
histoire que d'écrire une histoire dans
laquelle on peut se reconnaître et de
tendre un miroir d'essayer avec le plus
intime d'aller à une forme d'universelle
parce que tout le monde a eu 18 ans tout
le monde a connu le désœuvrement les
boîtes de nuit les les voilà le les
bières qu'on boit le soir les plages
l'après-midi la vacance pendant les
vacances bon tout le monde a connu aussi
des épreuves qui nous changent qui nous
transformment qui qui font que plus rien
n'est pareil après et c'est ça que je
veux raconter donc
j'esè j'espère que les et visiblement
les premiers retours de lecture me me
rassure sur ça c'est que les gens
reconnaissent une part de même puis
après il y a la nostalgie des ann 80 qui
sont devenus qui sont devenus très
vintage mais mais on peut tous passer à
côté de quelqu'un et de quelque chose
oui et ce qu'on retrouve aussi c'est le
fameux thème du transfuge de classe ce
qui est intéressant avec Philippe
vis-à-vis de Nicolas c'est que même si
Philippe il est très content de
retrouver ses amis d'enfance populaire
Nicolas il rate Nicolas il rate le bac
et d'une certaine manière Philippe il a
un peu de mépris social dont il s'en
veut vis-à-vis de Nicolas oui c'est le
moment où je bascule là aussi moi et je
deviens le transuche de classe moi je
suis essu d'une classe populaire j'avais
une mère secrétaire un père instituteur
on a manqué de rien mais on faisait
attention à tout bon et mes amis c'était
le fils du boucher le fils du pêcheur et
puis là cé étais là je sors de prépa ch
je vais aller faire une grande école je
suis déjà plein de certitude je j'irai à
la capit après je vais avoir un beau
métier tout ça j'ai droit à une forme
d'émancipation et et et les autres eux
ils vont rester là et donc j'ai envie de
rester avec eux parce que c'est mes amis
parce que je les aime parce que je me
reconnais en en eux parce que c'est mes
origines et en même temps je suis déjà
en train de m'en détacher je suis déjà
en train de les trahir parce que le
transfuge de classe est aussi un traître
à sa classe évidemment et donc je pars
là et je regarde Nicolas et je me dis
bah oui lui c'est aussi quelqu'un que je
vais laisser derrière et donc je m'en
veux je m'en veux parce que je me
comporte mal à ce moment-là sans doute
parce que je comprends pas la bascule
que je suis en train moi-même d'opérer
elle ressurgit encore cette histoire ou
depuis l'écriture c'est fini est-ce que
ce Philippe qui se retourne encore dans
la rue pour savoir si c'est pas Nicolas
cette silhouette il existe encore en
tout cas celui qui existe c'est celui
qui qui veut rendre hommage à son passé
qui veut rendre hommage à ceux qui ont
compté c'est-à-dire que je les oublie
pas euh ils sont ils sont pas là au
quotidien avec moi mais mais mais
disparu m'accompagne et donc écrire
c'est c'est la seule possibilité que
j'ai d'être encore avec eux donc de ne
pas me trahir tout à fait et de pouvoir
regarder le jeune homme de 18 ans que
j'étais en disant tu vois quand même tu
as tenu quelque chose il y a une il y a
une il y a une main qui que je n'ai pas
lâché h la culpabilité c'est fini le
remord ça ça continue de dévorer mais en
tout cas j'essaie de l'apaiser un peu
l'homosexualité aussi est à nouveau au
cœur de votre livre toute votre œuvre
d'ailleurs a permis à beaucoup de jeunes
homosexuels qui ont trouvé refuge dans
votre littérature sidentifiant à vos
histoires à votre histoire aussi les
moqueries les humiliations puis
l'acceptation de soi la société
française a beaucoup changé vous diriez
on a pour la première fois le premier
Premier ministre gay homosexuel ça a
fait la Une d'ailleurs aux États-Unis
oui aux États-Unis et pas en france d'
par qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire moi je
trouve que en tout cas peut-être que
c'est une bonne nouvelle qu'on en ait
pas parlé en France d'une certaine
manière ou moins parlé en France euh
parce que ça veut dire qu'au fond on
l'admet c'est c'est un fait comme ça on
sait qu'il est homosexuel le Premier
ministre et on valide on passe à autre
chose c'est pas une question au fond qui
est posée donc tant mieux je le prends
comme une bonne nouvelle euh après dès
que vous allez sur les réseaux sociaux
euh vous voyez qu'en en
revancheoromopobie torrent d'homophobie
des insultes des injures des propos qui
tombent sous le coup de la loi à non
plus finir donc ça veut dire que la bête
est encore là elle est tapie dans
l'ombre mais elle existe on parlait tout
à l'heure de de l'avortement pardon mais
moi j'ai rien oublié je suis le méchant
dans l'histoire hein j'ai rien oublié
dans 10 an de ça ceux qui aujourd'hui
nous expliquent que peut-être
l'avortement je ils étaient dans la rue
pour lutter contre le mariage pour tous
et il m'expliquait à moi que si je
voulais épouser mon compagnon je pouvais
tout aussi bien épouser un chien h et ça
vous j'oublie jamais jamais ça par
contre je pardonne pas voyez j'ai la
culpabilité mais il y a pas de pardon
non plus il y a pas de pardon pour ça
alors je suis très content quand
certains disent non non j'ai beaucoup
changer tant mieux on aurait préféré
qu'il disent pas de bêtises avant et
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
vigilant parce que parce que les ennemis
de l'intérieur sont encore là et puis il
y a la question du harcèlement aussi qui
est posé qui est un thème d'actualité
chez les plus jeunes on se rend compte
dès le collège on a on a besoin des
livres aussi pour expliquer çaou bah
surtout j'espère que les livres font que
les les les les jeunes filles ou les
garçons qui sont victimes de harcèlement
se sentiront moins seuls c'est moi c'est
ça que j'ai trouvé dans les livres quand
j'avais 16 ou 17 ans quand j'ai lu Hervé
Gubert quand j'ai lu Marguerite Duras je
me suis STI suis moins seul d'un coup et
je me suis dit tiens il y a des gens qui
parlent de moi ou qui racontent quelque
chose que je comprends ou qui me
ressemble cette question du harcèlement
souvent elle elle elle elle se
gangrainene parce que on prend pas la
parole parce qu'on reste avec avec les
injures avec les les insultes qui sont
proféré on n'ose pas dire à l'extérieur
on dit pas à ses parents on s'enferme
parfois ça finit très mal on le sait on
pense à Lucas thomas nicolas d'autres et
donc il faut il faut avoir conscience
qu'il y a là un monde souterrain et que
peut-être effectivement les chanteurs
les les écrivains les comédiens ont un
tout petit rôle à jouer pour dire voilà
on est là on est avec vous vous êtes pas
seul et merci de le jouer Philippe
Besson un soir d'été chez Juliard la vie
de Philippe de Nicolas et de ses amis
une disparition la fin de l'innocence
mais aussi beaucoup de questions c'est
aussi lumineux ce livre il faut le dire
merci à vous vous restez avec moi
Philippe Bessou parce que c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos chroniqueurs les a
franchis pour leur partiprix ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite allez venez Bertrand Perrier
maître Perrier qui a regardé la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel et les
réactions et puis lordordsi qu'on est
ravi d'accueillir bonsoir vous êtes
grand reporteur à Charlie Hebdo vous
nous parlez de la ministre de
l'Éducation dans un instant mais on va
commencer comme chaque vendredi soir par
action planè bonsoir Léa Falco dans le
collimateur de la FNSEA de la majorité
des agriculteurs il y a les normes
environnementales on en parle beaucoup
notamment europé
leur colère est-elle justifiée à vos
yeux bah c'est pas tant qu'elle soit pas
justifiée c'est que quand on regarde les
normes européennes à proprement parler
le Green Deal qui est le paquet
législatif de loi à Visé écologique de
l'Union européenne il a pas encore été
promulgué et donc concrètement il
n'existe ni en droit français ni en
droit européen aujourd'hui et en fait
même en écartant le Green Deal en France
on n'est pas spécialement zellé sur les
normes européennes je prends l'exemple
des pesticides en Europe on a le droit
de commercialiser jusqu'à 383 pesticides
et c'est les pays qui ensuite
choisissent en France on a le droit à
283 types de substances actives et en
fait il y a que l'Italie la Grèce et
l'Espagne qui en autorise plus à côté
l'Allemagne c'est 262 et la Pologne qui
pourtant est souvent pointée comme une
potentielle adversaire de l'agriculture
française c'est 265 soit presque 20 en
fait de moins chez nous et donc vous
trouvez queelle est diabolisé cette
avalanche de normes qui a fixirit les
les agriculteurs bah c'est qu'en fait
elle n'existe partiellement pas quand
même et puis c'est un discours qui est
circonscrit hein c'est c'est
principalement le discours de la FNSEA
donc un syndicat agricole plutôt à viser
industriel c'est la position aussi de
certains membres du gouvernement de
certains acteurs publics de certains
journalistes mais à bien y regarder on
pourrait appeler ça du Green blaming on
fait porter toute la colère paysane
agricole sur les normes européennes
alors qu'en fait elles ont assez peu de
rapport quand même avec tout le bousin
parce que quand on regarde les
revendications des agriculteurs qui sont
parfaitement légitimes c'est beaucoup
sur le revenu la répartition de la
valeur qui est liée au non respect de la
loi égalime qui est censée répartir
entre les
producteurs marge c'est ça dont les
marges continu continuent d'augmenter
c'est lié à ces questions de
rémunération fondamentalement il y a
aussi des questions d'empilement de
normees mais en fait c'est plus
administratif qu'écologique donc ENF en
fait quand on regarde ce que veulent les
agriculteurs qui sont quotidiennement au
contact de la terre c'est pas le droit
de polluer ou c'est pas le droit
d'utiliser des pesticides ce qu'ils
veulent et c'est parfaitement légitime
c'est de pouvoir vivre dignement de leur
travail et surtout que leur contribution
soit reconnu dans nos sociétés h vous
dites même qu'il faut plus de
transformation écologique de
l'agriculture bah oui parce qu'en fait
ce dont on a besoin c'est d'un
investissement dans notre modèle
agricole d'un investissement financier
et d'un CAP qui est fixé cet empilement
de norme il est aussi lié au fait que il
y ait des attentes contradictoires
aujourd'hui tout en disant à nos
agriculteurs de faire mieux de faire
plus vert on signe des accords de libre
échange qui font entrer dans nos
assiettes des produits moins 10 ans
écologiquement qui mettent en péril le
revenu nos agriculteurs ça ils le disent
l'agriculteur hein arrêtons d'importer
ce qu'on interdit chez nous bien sûr ils
le disent mais comment est-ce qu'on fait
ça avec plus de transformation
écologique en fait paradoxalement
contrairement à ce qui est dit par la
FNSEA parce que ça implique de de ne
plus réduire l'agriculture à une monnaie
d'échange il faut regardez ce que c'est
l'agriculture c'est le fondement de nos
sociétés donc en fait pour réussir à
assurer de meilleurs revenus pour avoir
une agriculture diversifiée qui permet
de bien faire vire les agriculteur il
faut de la planification et la
transformation écologique l'écologie
sera le salut de l'agriculture bah
écoutez il faut beaucoup beaucoup de
savoir faire de communication mais vous
êtes là pour les convaincre les
agriculteurs sonont les premiers écolog
ils sont au contact quotidien de la
terre donc merci pour ce parti prix
merci Léa Chalco on enchaîne pour vous
garder un petit peu de temps surtout
pour leur qui qui débarqu dans cette
émission on commence par Bertrand
Bertrand voulait revenir sur les
réactions de la classe politique
notamment à droite et à l'extrême droite
suscité par la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel guerre oui et alors on
assiste à un magnifique bal des cyniques
et des hypocrites un bal sur une Val à
tris temps premier temps la saisine du
Conseil constitutionnel qui s'est faite
dans des conditions absolument invra
semblable puisqu'on a vu un gouvernement
réclamer lui-même la censure d'un texte
qu'il avait fait voter au Parlement la
logique de nos institutions c'est qu'une
loi est votée que l'opposition la
conteste et que le gouvernement la
défend et bien là pas du tout avec un
cynisme assez incroyable et bien le
gouvernement qui avait cédé aux
exigences des LR au cours des débats
parlementaires en acceptant
l'introduction dans le texte de certains
arguments et bien se réjouit aujourd'hui
de leur censure par le Conseil
constitutionnel le comble du cyisme
c'est quand même de voter un texte que
l'on sait inconstitutionnel et de se
faire arakiri en saisissant soi-même le
Conseil constitutionnel en espérant que
celui-ci censure juridiquement ce à quoi
on na pas pu s'opposer politiquement le
deuxième temps de la Vals c'est la
décision en elle-même alors la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel parce que
évidemment le gouvernement pensait
espérait que le Conseil constitutionnel
serait en quelque sorte le blanchisseur
de sa conscience qu'il avait souillé
dans les débats parlementaires par cette
alliance contre nature avec la droite et
l'extrême droite sauf que on l'a vu le
Conseil constitutionnel ne s'est pas
prononcé sur le fond des dispositions
contesté sur leur conformité au droits
substantiels de la Constitution mais il
les a censuré pour une raison de
procédure c'est la question de ces
fameux cavalier c'est-à-dire ces
amendements qui sont censurés s'ils
n'ont pas de rapport suffisant avec le
texte initial déposé devant le Parlement
c'est donc une décision un peu en
demi-teinte un peu à minima qui
sanctionne plus un bricolage
parlementaire qu'une atteinte aux
valeurs de la République 3è temps les
réactions politiques alors l'hypocrisie
continue et la droite qui avait mangé
son pain blanc au cours de des
discussions parlementaires et s'était vu
très forte en disant qu'elle avait
imposé son texte au au gouvernement et
qu'elle lui avait tordu le bras et bien
maintenant déchante et nous ressort son
couplet habituel sur le gouvernement des
juges et la nécessité de faire un
référendum pour passer outre la censure
du Conseil consel en réalité s'il y a
bien une décision qui n'est pas un
gouvernement des juges c'est bien
celle-là puisque encore une fois le
Conseil constitionnel ne s'est même pas
prononcé sur le fond il a censuré pour
une raison procédurale et donc en fait
il n'a rien fait d'autre que de remettre
le débat entre les mains des politiques
en leur disant ça a été mal adopté si
vous vous sentez fort redéposez-le et
adoptez-le autrement il n'a pas interdit
de l'adopter il a interdit de l'adopter
comme ça a été adopté la réalité c'est
simplement que la droite a joué jou à un
jeu de DUP et qu'elle a perdu elle a
voulu faire un coup politique en forçant
l'adoption d'un certain nombre
d'amendements dont la constitutionnalité
était douteuse le Conseil
constitutionnel a rappelé que ça n'était
pas possible que la Constitution
l'interdisait et aujourd'hui le
gouvernement a beau jeu de pavoiser en
expliquant que le texte initial est
passé et ce qui est censuré c'est les
amendements Infiné on se serait quand
même bien passé de ce éniè débat sur le
rôle du Conseil constitutionnel qui en
fait dissimule un débat plus fondamental
sur l'état de droit cette règle
fondamentale qui fait que l'État est
soumis au droit que la volonté du peuple
n'est pas un absolu qu'elle s'exerce
uniquement dans un certain nombre
d'institutions de procédures et de
normes qui nous régissent et qui surtout
en matière d'immigration ne serait resté
étrangère merci magnifique parti prix
réaction c'est vrai que coup politique
jeu de dupe hypocr on est déjà dans une
défiance terrible vis-à-vis des
politiques le Faé va se creuser ça va
pas arranger les choses c'est c'est
brillant comme démonstration je suis
d'accord avec tout ce qui vient dit oui
c'est c'est un un un grand moment
d'hypocrisie ou alors c'est ultra bien
joué de la part du gouvernement qui
savait depuis le début que toutes les
toutes les dispositions qui qui lui
étaient pas favorable auxquell il
n'était pas favorable seraiit retoqué
mais enfin c'est c'est un spectacle
assez lamentable ENF il faut bien le
dire donc je pense qu'effectivement ça
ne peut qu'éloigner un tout petit peu
plus les Français de la chose politique
et on n pas besoin de ça en ce moment
parce qu'on sait qui en tirera les
bénéfices à la fin Lord aossi déjà
bienvenue je suis ravi de vous avoir
dans cette émission vous revenez sur les
nombreuses polémiques autour de la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale Amélie
ouea casterra sur ses conséquences mais
notamment sur la question de la lutte
contre le séparatisme et notamment
scolaire absolument c'était un véritable
feuilleton vous l'avez certainement
suivi on a d'abord découvert que les
enfants de la ministre sont scolarisés
dans le privé et non des moindres
puisque c'est le collège Stanislas
établissement catholique très
conservateur et élitiste de Paris puis
on a appris qu'un de ses fils comme
d'autres élèves du lycée auraient
bénéficié d'un système de contournement
du dispositif parcours sup et ces
derniers jours nouvelle polémique on
apprend que ces garçons étaient
scolarisés dans des classes non mixtes à
la non mixtité sociale s'ajoute donc
s'ajoute donc la non mixité fille garçon
les garçons de Stanislas vivent donc
dans un double getetto en quelque sorte
un getetto social avec uniquement des
riches et un ghetto de genre entre
garçons pour vous c'est un vrai problème
cette question de la non mixité oui
parce que la mixité est devenue l'un des
socles de l'école républicaine elle est
nécessaire pour apprendre à faire
société pour éviter de grandir dans
l'ignorance et l'incompréhension de
l'autre alors parfois la non mixité la
séparation fil garçon peut se comprendre
de manière exceptionnelle pour des cours
d' éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle par exemple pour permettre de
libérer la parole mais pour le reste
aucune raison d'être séparé dans l'école
de la République en tout cas cela doit
nous interpeller qu'une ministre de
l'éducation nationale choisisse ce type
d'établissement et accepte que ces
enfants soient scolarisés dans une
classe non mixte d'autant plus que cet
établissement est connu déjà pour des
prises de position très conservatrices
je rappelle queune enquête de L'Express
et de méia part avait révélé
des propos et des et un règlement très
sexiste comme le fait que les filles
devaient faire attention à leur tenue
pour ne pas éveiller le désir des
garçons et elles avaient même un livret
d'accueil dans lequel était inscrit si
tu es une fille veille sur ce point où
tu sais le garçon fragile ne fais rien
pour l'exciter ne l'allume pas
protège-le contre lui-même des garçons
se sont donc protégés au point d'être
totalement coupés des filles ces
fameuses allumeuses alors quelle
conséquences al alors et bien par ses
choix pour ses propres enfants la
ministre se situe ainsi en opposition
avec les engagements du gouvernement en
ce qui concerne notamment la lutte si
complexe et si délicate euh contre le
séparatisme religieux et en faveur de
l'égalité fille garçon car c'est bien
une forme de séparatisme que propose
Stanislas avec le repli sur les valeurs
religieuses et sur la non mixité ce ça
crée en fait une situation des plus
contre-productives hein pour le
gouvernement avec le risque de donner
l'impression d'un deux poids de mesur
avec les établissements de confession
musulmanes et donc on est en droit de se
demander maintenant quelle sera la
crédibilité la légitimité de cette
ministre bien la prochaine fois qu'il
faudra prendre des mesures contre
l'intégrisme religieux à l'école
Philippe Besson
réaction la pente qu'a dévalé Amélie oua
Castera elle ne la remontera jamais
je pense qu'elle est
cramée et je pense
que la multiplication des
polémique celle-ci est peut-être la pire
oui fait qu'elle devrait se retirer
d'elle-même elle doit partir pour vous
oui la cause qu'elle défend et
l'éducation nationale c'est quelque
chose de tellement important que ça
dépasse sa personne à elle elle est un
obstacle
aujourd'hui il faut il faut pas qu'on
soit
embarrassé par ce genre de chos-là la
non mixité c'est vrai que c'est le
sujet c'est la gooutte d'eau ça vous
choque CH Oui c'est très choquant enfin
je veux dire surtout quand on prétend
défendre l'école de la République les
valeurs républicaines précisément enfin
bon non c'est c'est ça devient vraiment
très compliqué je pense que néanmoins le
président de la République très décidé à
lui conserver sa confiance pourquoi vous
comprenez parce qu'il veut pas réagir au
au mouvement d'humeur de l'opinion et à
à une demande pressante il est connu
pour ça et je pense qu'il a tort je
pense qu'aujourd'hui l'éducation
nationale devrait avoir un ou une
ministre qui la défende et qui porte ses
causes et ses valeurs mieux qu'elle
merci pour cette réaction Lord ASI vous
voulez rajouter quelque chose non tout
est dit les conséquences politiques il
va falloir peut-être les tirer on attend
le le remanimement après le discours de
politique générale ce mardi qu'on suivra
bien sûr en direct sur LCP bien sûr
merci les affranchis et bon weekend
merci Léa merci Laur et merci Bertrand
et Merci à VOUS Philippe Besson d'être
passé sur le plateau d'lcp un soir d'été
chez Juliard ça cartonne déjà en
librairie mais vous pouvez allez allez
amplifier le le mouvement très belle
soirée c'est le weekend profitez bien à
la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine